sangeeta patel from ichi canada canada
canada
don't you love Canada it's a good play
what's the from Toronto Good Will
Hunting a lot of Good Will Hunting in
Toronto a movie called Hollywood land in
Toronto uh been to Toronto Film Festival
may be a great time it's a great place
to live it is cold but it's great time I
live in LA well that's that's a good
place to live is LA right it is it is
now I just watch a movie last night so
I'm still kind of going through the
whole process of what it's all about and
every little element it is raw it is
emotional and your performance is
powerful thank you so much the way you
brought Jack to life you took it you
took it to that place thank you knowing
that you were gonna make this film
you're doing this process or telling
your truth what have you learned about
yourself through this process and has it
been therapeutic for you in any way one
of the things I've learned about is that
I think I've become more two things as
I've gotten older I think I've gotten to
a place where my own standards have
start to become more important than
whether everybody else likes it when I
started out as an actor you know
watching how's my audition was it good -
what are they saying to someone so that
you know and increasingly it's become
like what is the experience like for me
personally and in that sense this movie
is like a gigantic hit for me I don't
know how it's gonna do at the box office
I don't know critics are gonna say but
for me personally it was just a
wonderful experience that I would love
to be able to replicate over and over
again and and that was because of the
actors I worked with it was because the
opportunity to play emotional and honest
scenes it was the chance to work with
Gavin again there are a lot of reasons
why I first question was like bringing
my own stuff like yes I'm a recovering
alcoholic and I'm playing a guy who gets
into recovery that never fazed me that
much it's actually pretty common there
are a lot of people who've been through
that kind of thing right yeah get better
and a lot of our actors are right then
go back and write you know Tennessee
Williams or William Faulkner or you know
mankiewicz or you know it but I did
feel responsibility to to get it right
and there is a I don't wanna give it
away but there's something that has
happened to this character in his life
that it has thank God not happened in my
life and I and I wouldn't wish it on
anybody and that was to me that was the
stretch that was the reach where I need
to be able to go for a level of grief
that I'm not experienced in my life and
try to express that and as authentically
as I can as an actor and that's what
scared me about the room thank you for
talking your truth to I mean it's gonna
help a lot of people okay and its motion
watching you in this character thank you
is there certain parts of the movie
that's difficult for you to watch even
though you're and I do think it's nice
too I'm not a preacher or sermonize or
an expert or anything but I can say that
I do think it is nice I've got a lot of
nice letters and stuff from people who
whose family members are struggling with
struggling themselves and the idea that
like you know things actually do get
better you know what I mean it you can
deal with it and move on and have a life
and I know a lot of really really strong
honest people with integrity who've been
through this and it's kind of made the
better people so you know it's an
opportunity for growth and change and
that was what I really wanted to to
express good question
basketball what just quickly basket
basketball all-time player LeBron James
or Michael Jordan Kobe Bryant oh wow
those are Kobe yeah it's always been
closing off number three on scoring
right foreigner I'm going with LeBron
James then I might go with Jordan
Jordan's my heyday Jordan was like my
that's right there because we're like
six years old